uh well
the
that's what's killing the kids that's
the real monster that's how you do it
hellfire's own pulls off some impressive
improv joseph quinn goes full-on eddie
munson performing his stranger things
monologue in different accents yeah
people seem to be responding to it the
actor stopped by the tonight show with
jimmy fallon and wait until you hear his
spot-on accent
liverpool okay
ball
but as long as you're into bands or
science
or parties
that's pretty good
my mom's from liverpool and she sounds
exactly like that hopefully joseph's mom
doesn't mind him poking a little fun at
her expense but it's his scottish accent
that has us blown away
we're the freaks because we like to play
a fantasy game
and while the british actor proves he
can nail an american accent on the
netflix series
what are you even looking for madonna
blondie bowie beetles music we need
music
joseph pulls out his east coast swag for
the game
new york oh
and sports conformity
since joining season four of stranger
things there's no denying eddie's been a
big hit with fans
[Music]
earlier this month joseph got a little
emotional speaking with e.t
were you aware of the amount of love
that that eddie
has it's kind of it's a completely
overwhelming feeling it's it's so lovely
like the
the devotion that the fans have for the
show how they've found space in their
heart but for a new character eddie is
just so it's heartwarming and these days
the 28 year old actor is definitely
feeling the feels
you know we are so grateful and
thank you
joseph was recently brought to tears
after fans at london's comic con made it
clear they really really like him
i think that we've already connected
with eddie for one reason or another
whether we like his music taste or that
he is the outsider like you mentioned
[Music]
yeah we love eddie but we also love
joseph so just for good measure i'm
going to leave you with another one of
his impressive accents
australian oh
or a bloody guy where you toss bloody
balls into bloody baskets
[Music]